[Applause]
but I actually that's the way I prefer
to write and this is my room this is my
little trick that none of you will want
to do I will write a draft and then I'll
put it away for a year uh or even two
years or even three years and then I'll
come back to it and I'll read it and I
go who wrote this [ __ ] and then I will
read it like maybe two or three times
and then I will throw that away and then
rewrite it from page one based on the
memory of how of what I read and then my
120 page script will suddenly be 80
pages and it'll just be the Bare Bones
and just like the important parts or the
memory the things that I can remember
remember from reading the script and so
I think there's a there's a quite a good
filter system and then when you have
like this very sort of bare bones short
version of your story then you can add
back in some tonal stuff and some yeah
more jokes and [ __ ] and stuff like that
but yeah so that takes a long way longer
than anyone wants to do